people sometimes here in the US stinks
cabins died but it grew in other parts
of the world and then it leaked back
into the Latin ska bands that we have in
LA most people in the rest of the world
don't expect Latinos in LA to listen to
ska music or even know about it but it's
what we do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Clement Therese I'm a
musician producer I'm most of the guy
behind the biggest ska punk events we
have in LA I grew up running around in
the streets of Linwood Compton and South
Gate I got shot at a few times I got
mugged a few times if I didn't have
music and I didn't have the ska punk
shows to go to I don't know where I
would have been Latin ska punk has
influences from all over the place it's
a genre that collects bits and pieces of
everything from Jamaican reggae to
hardcore to the Mexican Latin Scott it's
just a clash of everything
[Music]
Latin ska started popping up in LA in
the mid late 90s it was in the
neighborhood we had a hard time playing
legitimate venues that's kind of what
sparked me having to organize some of
these events because no one would do it
for us I think a lot of these Latino
kids in the neighborhoods are attracted
to ska music the way people dance the
way people dress they just find
themselves in that the rhythm really
gets you going it touches a lot of
people so a lot of these kids that go to
our shows it helps them find themselves
it makes them feel like they do belong
to something it's a very personal
connection to them it's something that
you feel I can actually people
automatically I don't think there's a
better feeling you can kind of move the
night with the music and the energy of
the people can also move me it just
really builds fulfilling
[Music]
hi I'm angel I'm Jen we're it's when DJs
and producers what makes a good DJ's
being observant if I play one track and
I'm just like everybody really responded
to that it's going in your head in a
split second I've got ten of the tracks
of sound just like that we do switch off
usually every 30 minutes she can kind of
like move off of what I did when we're
not playing we're watching the audience
still be playing and I'll come over and
we're up with like cleanup mix I know
when my twin has it will be okay we open
the bar up in the bronx new york and
it's a religion making area a lot of
reggae playing out in the streets all
the time in fifth grade we entered this
program that helps inner-city youth that
are generally underprivileged
we got very lucky but some kids don't
get as lucky we got through middle
school in high school and we got into
Dartmouth and we both decided to go so
when we graduated we came back to the
city I was playing with equipment on and
off I went home one day and I told her
like this is what we have to do after
you graduate from college nobody's
thinking you'll then go on to become a
DJ it was one of those moments we had to
be resolute and what you were doing
there's no kick yet and then the base
hits I kind of like it I think DJ is
definitely a predominantly male industry
we've heard some negativity from not
even other DJ's but people and audiences
and I think it's been surprising just
because it doesn't feel like a jiaying
should be a gendered thing I take a
burden upon myself to perform better
because we are women we do get a lot of
good feedback from girls and women who
want to learn it do you want to learn
how to DJ if someone told me that I
would end up being a professional DJ
with angel I would not have wasted what
you follow what you like then you follow
your dreams it can take you anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot of places that don't let
me perform simply because I'm black
and that doesn't really get to me
because I'm trying to show the world
that you know music is universal it can
unite us all my name is Ryan Lory and
I'm also known as campanero and
compañero simply means the black friend
I seem rational musica mexicana panda
CEO Daniel Norteno mariachi little I've
been around Hispanic so I mean it
actually comes naturally it flows out I
grew up in the streets of Compton I
lived in a neighborhood that was
predominantly black and Mexican it's a
wonderful thing to say you know I came
from Compton because they say a lot of
people don't make it out I've traveled
to a lot of places and I'm all over TV
and I can say hey I'm from Compton
a lot of people tell me like hey you're
supposed to be Mexican God just left in
the oven too long I know for a fact that
I am african-american but yeah I do feel
like I live that light I have lived a
run channel life I've had horses I've
had research goats eggs everything I
know how to saddle up a horse your honor
making dance and everything a lot of
people misunderstand and say hey you're
trying to be Mexican too much I'm like
wow there are American Cowboys there are
people who use boots and just that's
what I was taught what I've been around
but yes like I said in my summer but
like I said in my song I have the heart
and soul of a Mexican and that I think
that that pretty much is what counts
[Music]
as far as prisons go if we have to be
here we need something to reform of and
music is a direct expression of what we
feel we want to be and to let go other
things that we don't want anymore
[Music]
at Lee Correctional Institution a
maximum-security prison in South
Carolina the new york-based Chamber
Orchestra Dakota spends a week a year
working with inmates to write music
the inmates included in this program are
chosen by merit nor prime musical
experiences necessary right I want to
learn this in chunks because you guys
are teaching us the thumb now which is
totally radical and often
before I was never exposed to classical
music or chamber music or anything that
was cultured honestly I closed myself
off to a world of expression that I
never really knew existed we have an
opportunity in this program to put away
the violence and all these other mediums
of expression that do nothing but hurt
people and we can channel those feelings
and expressions into music
[Music]
when we're able to practice and actually
get together and just for that moment
just just for that little bit of time
you're able to take your armor off for
once and just breathe it's been a big
tool to help me change we have a phrase
that we use we have to act hard you know
act tough put on sort of a facade and we
can channel those feelings and
expressions into music which is the most
positive way to express yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our mariachi florida Toloache is
different than most varieties were
formed in New York City
we're all women most people think of
mariachis being from Mexico as being men
as being macho and you know were pretty
much opposite of all those things I
started my musical career playing with a
local ohm el Mariachi in Brooklyn for me
was really hard to communicate with
other male mariachis because of the
machismo
that's very vivid and the culture and in
the genre that's right yeah that's kind
of why I wanted to start my own group
and that led for me to do a all-female
group because I didn't want to deal with
men and it's not so much that people say
you're not already achieve but it's the
fact that they think that we cannot play
my deity because we're women and we're
wearing pens and we have curly hair and
we don't look Mexican or we don't have
this look that they're expecting
as a women buddy actually we're
technically supposed to be wearing
skirts and it didn't work for us that's
one of the most passionate music that
I've ever heard it was just beautiful
it's very hard felt and I think that's
what makes my day actually so special my
dream to be able to perform and connect
with people through music I don't think
I could ask for more that's what keeps
us going in there thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]